you find your insurance paperwork no I
only have the old one my dad hasn't sent
me a copy of it okay
um ma'am I believe your driving could
possibly be impaired by alcohol I'm
gonna have you step out and do a couple
of tests real quick see if you're okay
to keep driving go and step out for me
do you have any medical limitations
impairments that affect your ability to
walk in balance
um I do have an autoimmune disease
called the Shay syndrome okay yeah
syndrome
um the last time I was diagnosed I was
about the third person in New Mexico to
have it okay
um it's very similar to lupus okay all
right I'm gonna have you try these tests
as best you can and we'll go from there
okay yes sir do you feel comfortable
walking in those shoes
does your autoimmune
disease or whatever it is does it does
it affect your ability to walk in
balance
um at times I do get lesions inside of
my intestines I did go to the doctor
last week for a lesion that I have okay
and did they give you something for it
do you think it's better they haven't
done anything okay so the lesion inside
your intestine does that affect your
ability to walk and balance as far as I
know I've known okay all right put your
feet together like this for me put your
arms out of your pockets and down by
your side I'm going to be looking at
your eyes
hold that let me move my hair
oh okay arms down at your side please be
looking at your eyes and you should
watch the tip of this pin right here
with your eyes and your eyes only don't
move your head just your eyes do you
understand yes sir
try to hold your head still please
keep watching it I need you to look at
it
very good
four five
six
seven eight nine after
E F G H I J K L M N O P Q okay do you
know your numbers
can you count backwards for me start at
47 and end at 32 please
47-32 yes
um 47 46 45
44 43 42 43 40.
uh 39 38 37
36. how much alcohol have you had
tonight I've only had one vodka soda
about how long ago
about like two hours ago okay I feel
like your driving is possibly impaired
by alcohol I these tests are not pass
fail but I feel like you did poorly on
them what's gonna happen is I'm going to
give you a chance to take a breath test
um that is something that is required
but in order to take that test I do have
to place you under arrest for DWI so
turn around for me please
go ahead so
I'm pretty sure
the Press test is by
willingness okay go ahead and turn
around for me we'll I'll read you the
implied consent and you can decide for
yourself you're not going to be forced
to take it uh you do have to provide a
breath sample but it's going to be your
choice turn around for me put your hands
behind your back
go to your left you are under arrest for
driving under the influence of an
intoxicating liquor or drug the New
Mexico implied consent act requires you
to submit to a breath test to determine
the alcohol content of your blood after
you take our test you have the right to
choose an additional independent test
if you choose to take this additional
independent test you have the right to a
reasonable opportunity to arrange for a
physician a licensed nurse or laboratory
technician or technologist who is
employed by a hospital or physician of
your own choice to perform an additional
chemical test the cost of this
additional test will be paid for by the
law enforcement agency the Albuquerque
Police Department
do you agree to take our test it will be
a breath test
constant breath
a little constantly Harden constantly
tell the machine stops making noise go
ahead
[Music]
try it again
you have the legal limit in the state of
New Mexico is .08 your first press score
was a 0.16 and your second was a 0.16
you're over two times you're at two
times it's a little bit more than one
shot okay
0.08 is the the point O eight is the
legal limit
you are going to be transported out to
MDC where you'll be booked for DWI
you're also going to be booked for fail
to maintain a traffic lane failed to
obey a traffic control device and for
not having your proof of insurance in
the vehicle
if you have any questions for me do I
need to make a phone call you'll be able
to make a phone call once you get
processed booked photographed
fingerprinted
Turn Around for Me hands back behind
your back
how long
no how long did you fight though oh
do you ever have your nose broken
11 years
you want to talk to your mom
do you want to tell you got arrested yes
from boxing to bikini huh
it's a good transition I think you did
the similar didn't you yeah
hello yes sir my name is Officer Brill
um Sergeant Dexter just came over wanted
me to talk to you a little bit uh where
are you coming from tonight uh I was
about to kind of bouncing around I
watched a friend of mine's okay Lolo
okay yeah all right how much have you
had to drink tonight oh it's two beers
two beers how long ago
um
probably like
10 30 11 yeah so about two hours up to
an hour ago okay did you have food with
those beers yeah it was pizza okay
um are you diabetic or epileptic do you
take insulin for any reason any other
medications
okay whenever you step out of the
vehicle okay
what I'm gonna have you do is put your
feet together okay arms down at your
sides I want you to remain in that
position until I tell you otherwise you
wear contacts or glasses no no okay you
see the tip of my pen yes what I want
you to do is follow it with your eyes
and your eyes only would you be able to
do that
nope don't move your head
don't move your head
what do I have you do because you're
having difficulty keeping your head
still yeah take your fists put them just
like this okay that way your head won't
move back and forth okay
see the tip of the pen follow it with
your eyes and your eyes only
you can blink if you need to
all right I'm gonna have to reach up but
we're gonna go up
one more time
you said you have a knee injury
okay
um is that the scar there on your leg
there oh I got a bunch of them scars
here screws there okay what's that on
your pants there
yep oh it's uh it's some dirt from the
dog okay dirt from Doug okay
all right
so I'm not gonna have you do any of the
walking turn or anything like that just
because of your injury okay all right
I'm gonna have you do is blow into this
it's not admissible in court just
verifies what I'm already seeing
okay that's fine
go ahead and get your hands out of your
pockets right now you are under arrest
for DUI
sir I'm gonna take off your watch real
quick just because I don't want that to
get in the way
I wouldn't want it to get broken or
anything like that
is there a clock spotted or
you've been Cooperative so I'll let you
secure that you want to put it in your
pocket okay
I'm fine with that
thank you I'm gonna give you two sets of
cuffs just because you got some wider
shoulders and so undo your hands there
you go
and then I'm going to double lock these
so they don't get any tighter on you
kind of come towards me there you go I'm
going to search you before I put you in
your car so go ahead and spread your
feet for me
all right go ahead and have a seat in my
vehicle
I do want you to know that you have the
right to remain silent anything you say
Canon will be used against unicortola
you have the right to the presence of an
attorney to assist you prior to
questioning to be with you during
questioning if you desire if you cannot
afford an attorney you have the right to
have an attorney appointed for you prior
to questioning do you understand your
rights yes sir all right I'm going to be
right back with you okay
done okay no you're you're really done
now
because now you're drunk driving
and you know the officers were nice
enough earlier
they're nice enough to take you to make
sure that you got home
and for your brother to come and get you
so that you weren't drunk driving
anymore
and you left there and drunk Drive some
more
money
you're impaired driving and you're not
supposed to be driving drinking and
driving
[Applause]
turn around here face me get a chance
down your side for me hands down your
side switch feet together
I have uh dementia okay
I'm an airplane pilot okay
[Applause]
it's fine what do you want to do put
your feet together like I said
brother
what are you gonna do are you gonna do
the exercise or not yes or no
are you gonna do the exercise yes or no
are you gonna sir I'm asking a simple
question it's very easy I have to do is
answer it you're gonna do the exercises
yes or no sorry
I just asked you to step out here and do
what I told you to do
okay stay out here put your feet
together for me tight okay just like
this put your feet like mine okay better
to get like shorter than the other one
okay tighter together
beverage look look let me show you
something real quick okay okay I'm sure
you got all kinds of issues I'm sure as
we go I'm sure there'll be me anymore
okay no we're done put your feet
together okay get your piece together
like mine a fair minor
can you look at my feet see how my feet
are can you put your feet like that yeah
okay yeah
it's not like mine but anyway
what I want you to do is see this blue
light just follow whatever your eyes
don't move your head you understand yeah
you got it you understand
keep them on I'm going to bed
right here you're gonna do what I ask
you to do right now yes sir follow us
with your Iceberg okay
wherever that goes that's where I need
to be okay not
I'm having a tough time with this by the
way okay good I'm sure
I am
follow my followers Samuel
do it
two three no I'm up I told you I'm
done what do you mean you're done
are you gonna finish the exercise or not
I'll do whatever you want to be well
then how about you do that and how about
you quit trying to interrupt me
okay stop what are you supposed to do
now go home no no don't punch me in my
chest
okay again all right next exercise is
going to be the oil one leg standing
gonna do that
yeah okay
let me settle myself
just tell yourself by holding onto my
car no
no this is an exercise that doesn't
require you holding on to my police car
you're at the book on DUI yeah I don't
drive okay well you do today
okay go ahead and go ahead and stick
your foot out for me all right sir go
ahead and take your foot out for me
please
don't hold on to my car okay
can you listen you're walking me all the
way to the back of my car no put your
hands down to your side no sir don't put
your hands on me let's go through a few
more tests one more we're not going
through any more tests you're done well
quit resisting I'm not resisting yo when
you start pulling away
trust me I've done this for 32 years
I've done it for 38. so I got you beat
I just need some more okay
we're gonna ask you to submit their
breathalyzer test you're gonna do that
no no okay
the he's a no-owner breathalyzer
put your brother to come and get your
truck
he's on the next street over
um yeah
barely your girlfriend's impaired so
she's not going to be coming again
that's cool you're right
I don't know
where's your ID at you have driver's
license my hands are behind them okay
they're not it's not on you so where is
it
I don't think so
earlier but
I have every handcuffed myself
okay there's your right front pocket and
there's nothing in there there's nothing
in there nope
um well maybe it's in your truck
let's go see if the wallets in there
yep
still okay Mr Hardings I'm gonna read
your uh I'm gonna still I still have to
read them to them even though you say
you know them it's not Miranda it's
implied consent okay
um Sergeant peck of the Volusia County
Sheriff's Office I'm prepared to offer
you opportunity to submit to a test to
determine the content of alcohol in your
blood or breath or the presence of any
chemical or Controlled Substances
they're in any refusal to submit to such
a test or test
would result in the suspension every
driver's driving privilege to operate a
motor vehicle for a period of one year
for a first refusal or a period of 18
months if your driving privilege has
been previously suspended for refusing
to submit to a such tests or tests
you're committing a misdemeanor if you
have refused to submit to a lawful test
as requested and your driving privilege
has been previously suspended
for a prior refusal to submit to a test
the lawful test of your breath blood or
urine if you hold a commercial driver's
license or you are operating a
commercial motor vehicle this refusal
will result in a disqualification of
your commercial driver's license
privilege for a period of one year for a
first refusal or permanently if you're
driving privilege has been previously
disqualified
you understand that yes sir okay you
still refusing to take the breath test
yes okay
and you understand that this this entire
encounter from the start to finish has
been recorded on on body cam video
all right sir I'm just playing
you know I'm not violent can you
handcuff me to the problem we're going
to take care of that we get to the
station just drove up and hit the cement
parking divider really hard can you turn
your radio down
so the reason I'm stopping you sir is
when you made your left turn onto Sadler
Road from eighth you drove over the lane
it's marked over you can't drive over
that marked area that's called a Gore
you understand yeah okay my senior
license registration proof of insurance
so have you been drinking yes or no
sir no you can't make eye contact with
me when you say that
so you're gonna be honest
no you're not gonna be honest okay all
right sir gonna step out of the vehicle
for me
where were you coming from prior to me
just stopping you
I dropping my daughter off in Bible
school which is where at
at um St Michael's okay
okay give me just a minute just hang out
right there you can relax okay
laughs
you know who this is
this is going to be ASA Sarah Bell's
husband
will you go up to him and see if you
smell something I feel like I'm getting
a paint odor off his breath I want to
make sure
yeah so I thought
okay
all right so I'm now I'm gonna read you
your rights because I am conducting a
DUI investigation too I smelled Urban
alcoholic beverages as well as Deputy
Gordon here so both of us smell it it's
not just fictitious okay
so you do have the right to remain
silent anything you say Canon will be
used against human affordable law you do
have the right to speak to an attorney
and to have an attorney present during
any questioning if you cannot afford a
lawyer we won't be provided for you at
no cost before any questioning begins if
you answer if you do answer questions
now you do have the right to stop
answering anytime Consulting attorney
you understand your rights yes okay so
how much have you had to drink today as
far as alcohol goes
okay I don't believe you neither does he
no okay but can you get me home no
no please no
no
why are you different than anybody else
I stop and do a DUI investigation with
because who your wife is don't work that
way bud don't work that way okay you're
not privileged because of what your wife
does for a living okay so you want to
tell me how much you've had to drink
today or not
okay understood on a scale of zero to
ten with zero being completely sober and
10 being drunk or intoxicated what would
you rate yourself on that scale right
now sure okay
and you said you just dropped your
daughter off right yeah
so you would feel safe driving with a
child in your car
obviously obviously
okay did you really have a stroke three
years ago
yeah
because I'd hate for you to be lying to
me about that that's not something you
shouldn't lie about okay
are you willing to perform Phil sobriety
exercises no
no okay I do have to inform you that cam
used against you in court later if you
do refuse to do them you know that
already okay is there a reason you won't
perform food sobriety exercise
what do you mean you can't
my stroke
even if they don't require you to move
at all
if I just okay for instance there's one
where I just look at your eyes and you
follow my finger or my pen now look at
your eyes you wouldn't be able to do
that why not
stroke
you're moving your eyes fine right now
sir you should be able to do that
there's no reason you shouldn't be able
to do that if you can't move your eyes
like that you can't drive
because that's not a good excuse
okay
okay so you're willing to do that or not
you say the alphabet
you can do that would you be willing to
do that yes okay through Zeba do not
wrong
hang on do not rhyme it or sing it like
the song okay I compare it saying it
kind of like a robot like this hey
d c d e and so forth and so on a b c e f
g h i your eyes need to remain closed
your head needs to be tilted back sir
j k l o n
the reason you're stopping
because you move to White
what does that have to do anything sir
you want to start over put your feet
together listen put your feet together
your hands not your sides tilt your head
back close your eyes and recite the
alphabet A through Z keep your eyes
closed and keep your head tilted back
okay
QRS TV WR Jackson
Elementary
what's your highest level of Education
sir
what NBA you can't recite the alphabet A
through Z
I just did no you didn't sir
you did you knew you didn't all right
let's try another one gonna tilt your
head back close your eyes and we're
beginning
30 seconds are you telling me to stop
sir yeah okay that's 52 seconds okay
you will or you will not let me look at
your eyes
with moving a stimulus in front of your
eyes
are you willing to let me do that or not
no okay
all right
what about the um
the finger to nose exercise
are you willing to do that one
that's not I mean I'd have to get the
instructions but somewhat like that are
you willing to do that one
are you willing to participate in that
exercise okay
okay left
keep your eyes closed and keep your head
tilted back okay right
okay keep you got to keep your eyes
closing your head till the back okay
during the entire exercise left
right
right so because you've said you've had
a stroke I'm not going to ask you to
stand on one leg I'm not going to have
you perform
the walk and turn exercise unless you
think you can do it
no okay and you will not let me do
the eye exercise okay so you've limited
me on what I can I can do with you okay
but based on what I've seen so far I do
feel like you are DUI and you are going
to be placing an arrest for DUI okay so
place your hands behind your back for me
relax your arms sir
[Music]
turn your body
I'll get just situated here okay
how tall are you
six two okay
here we go
there we go
hi there
you okay
what's your name sir officer derosier
San Antonio Police Department if you're
curious okay you all right
no no
do you realize your jeep's still running
your name Clayton yeah okay do you
realize you were potentially involved in
a motor vehicle accident tonight Clayton
no can you sit up no do you want help
sitting up no
I can't exactly leave you like this
oh shoot man if you can't stand up on
your own I'm gonna have to call an
ambulance because I can't leave you with
an inability to care for yourself no
I'm sorry let's try sitting up let's
start with that all right
hey we're making progress
oh shoot Jeff ID on you Clayton no no
I'm not
2120 826 yes or no question not a
Hammer aren't do you have ID on you no I
don't know do you have a driver's
license no
but you were out driving
no I'm not
no not right now but you were out
earlier now because I have a description
that you match out of Bill Millers
I have a receipt from right behind your
vehicle with some groceries from earlier
today okay and when I said you left your
vehicle running you reacted in such a
way that would lead me to believe that
you're operating it earlier it appears
that you might have been driving while
intoxicated
so you don't have a driver's license
that would be an even worse decision
wouldn't you agree yes okay can you
stand up no have you been drinking
tonight oh no I'm just I'm trying to get
into my house okay so why is that so
difficult
well
you know what time it is right now no I
don't even know what time is it were you
driving earlier no
who was I'm like well I I ask a lot of
questions that I already know the answer
to yeah so the more you lie to me just
the harder this is yeah for you easier
for me harder for you right so who's
driving
not me not you no who was
and what kind of bum friend do you have
that would leave you lying in your
backyard
well
um back here and I just I'm sorry
I'm surprised you haven't even asked
about the people that you hit if they're
okay or not what yeah you were involved
in a more vehicle crash tonight at least
your vehicle was so I'm gonna call an
ambulance out because at this point I
can't just leave you here okay so we'll
go from there all right
thank you
let's start with your last name
Clayton Perry Clayton Perry yes
I just came on home
from
yeah
normally this fuzzy on details no no no
okay are you just avoiding my question
or are you confused no that's more of a
medical concern than anything on this
[Music]
had a good time where
from just right yeah
okay so you're having a good time right
down the road we're talking like Mud
Creek Elementary School Bill Miller's
like where how far down the road uh from
um this rat down the road were you out
of business a friend's house hanging out
on the side of the road nope from uh
when you were having this good time how
much did you have to drink
well I had a good time what does that
mean
just had a good time what does that mean
well had a good time
was it the people you were with the
beverages you were drinking the music
you were tapping your foot to like what
does that mean yeah had a good time
did you like your driver's license back
before you dip inside
yes
can you get inside
I appreciate it
yeah just so you understand
I do have a crash report to write your
vehicle is going to be listed in that
crash report because that witnesses that
saw it occur and following you back here
okay I'm also going to be filing a stock
failure to stop and provide information
okay so just remember what's happening
with all that
if you have any questions for me okay
nope
not for me go ahead and go inside
um just so you know the back tailgate of
your Jeep is open
and the windows down on the driver's
side okay all right well I appreciate it
thank you very much yes sir it's all
right all right Jordan hop inside all
right
okay
I can't leave till I see you inside okay
I don't think the keys are in there I'm
tired I don't think your keys are in
there if that's what you're looking for
okay all right keys are in the in the I
don't know where the keys are okay I'm
saying if you're looking for them I
doubt they're in your wallet okay all
right well I appreciate it thank you
very much I appreciate it are you an
injuring your residence or no
I'm sorry are you going to be entering
your residence or no yes okay yeah
I got it thank you appreciate it
there's no pad there for your for a card
to unlock
yeah that's a credit card
still no card that's gonna open that
door sir
guess what there's no card that's going
to open that door
I've seen him try about six now well
it's just a standard lock you need a key
all right well
I know
well I'm sorry me too I can't get into
the into the house what do you want me
to do my bathroom do you want me to
check your vehicle for Keys maybe you
have a house key then we can try the
front door with sorry or did the mystery
driver run off with those two yeah
I don't know I'm sorry can may I search
your vehicle for your house keys
the house keys yeah we're at your house
okay
yes I can search your vehicle for house
keys well I need to get into the house
when the door is locked usually Keys
okay
um
hang on just a second I've been waiting
for a lot I'm gonna ask one more time
after that I'm gonna leave you to your
own devices I'm sorry I'm gonna ask you
one more time if you answer no I'm gonna
leave you to your own devices because
you refuse to EMS and they said that
you're competent to make decisions so
yeah would you like me to search your
vehicle for your house keys yes or no uh
no sir
do not drive anymore tonight do you
really should run the red light
underneath the interstate
okay yeah there's a red light and
there's a second red light
you don't remember the first one no I
didn't see yeah okay you got your last
registration
is anyone in the car been drinking yeah
no you're the one's being drinking
tonight okay just because the way you're
driving and and what's going on we'll
make sure it's okay if we drive until
you're not even consistent any alcohol
at all no ice
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna move it
back and forth you're gonna fall with
your eyes and your eyes only while you
keep your head still okay okay just
gonna keep your head still and fall off
your eyes okay
thank you
I'm sorry I'm sorry you can blink like
normal
it's gonna slow down a little bit just
keep falling with your eyes one two
three four five
five yep just like I showed you
ready okay whenever you're ready
until I tell you to stop
remember you look at the toe of the foot
where you cannot loud
tell me how long ago you're gonna keep
counting until you tell you to stop
11 12. remember look at the two of the
four you count out loud
this next part going to put your feet
together Put Your Arms by your side do
not move until I tell you to
based on my observations tonight I do
believe you are too impaired to be
driving
so we are being placed under arrest for
DUI tonight
I'm tired
tell me what
uh well you first start over when
they're in the red light that'd be the
first part I didn't run
around actually thought you meant you
did we're gonna step back to my vehicle
foreign
[Music]
I understand that like you don't like
probably pretty people because they
don't like you but like
the fact that you target them
I did not mess up one part of that test
so I would love to see the playback
okay you know why I'm stopping you
no idea okay you ran a red light back
there at Howard and Kennedy what's that
okay do you have your registration with
you
much have you had to drink tonight I
haven't drink anything okay what about
marijuana use do you smoke marijuana
recently no no no okay she's got
marijuana Shake all over your face
I planned on it but I
but okay all right let me check your
license okay
sure
try to keep your head still
perhaps counting your steps out loud as
you walk down this line okay one why
don't want you to start yet okay two I
don't want you to start yet when I tell
you to so go ahead and put your left
foot on the line right foot in front of
your left foot so it touches Heel To Toe
arms down to your side great now I'll
tell you I'll tell you when to start
okay okay but I have to first show you
how to do it you can begin when you're
ready
my legs are really sore so this is
actually okay do the best you can
four small steps and then one two
three
four
five six seven eight
nine
ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
if you understand how to do it then you
can begin when you're ready
make sure you're counting out loud
I don't have a lot of balance I have a
lot of core strength just continue
okay you can put your foot down all
right next we're gonna face this way
again we'll put your feet together like
this arms straight down to your side
just like that okay
put both your arms back together like
they're praying just like this okay
so hold me don't interlace your fingers
quite yet just hold them like that where
you're praying okay
and and understand if you haven't been
drinking the medicines that you've taken
are certainly impairing you
so I was never told like
it probably says them right on the
bottom no it does not I promise I'll
show you my bottle right now okay is it
in the card yes it is in the car I'll
show you right now come on up here
do you have let me ask you a very
important question do you have anything
illegal on you or in your pocket no no
no no okay because there's marijuana
Shake on you is there any marijuana
hidden on you anywhere nope
did you have a female for search
if if there's a female coming okay if
they search you and miss something in
their search and they find it when they
get at the jail it's an additional
felony charge okay right now you're only
looking at a misdemeanor charge okay
okay
so like I said we are going to go down
to the jail okay and I'm going to ask
you to do a breath test when we get
there okay are you willing to do that
what are my rights
well you don't have to take the breath
test okay you can refuse it there's no
penalty for refusing it I don't think
there is I gotta look at your driving
have you ever been arrested before yeah
so if that's true
that's true then there's there's
um no additional charge for refusing the
breath test okay however what it changes
is it changes the um length of
suspension that goes on your license
okay it turns out if you refuse it it's
a one-year suspension on your license
okay
does that answer your question
okay are you willing to do that when we
get to jail
I can't hear you
you don't know yet okay I'll give you
some time to think about it okay
we don't need a warrant to Search Your
Heart okay you do no not after when
you've been arrested on a traffic stop
out of a vehicle
um there's it's a it's a warrantless
search okay what happens is
okay I'm just explaining to you what's
gonna happen okay either you can stand
up and let me get them out or we can
force you to do it okay I'm not lying to
you everything's on camera I have no
reason to lie to you okay
bunch of like looks like uh just little
butts left of marijuana joints
spice grinder spice grinder with a
residue
spice Grinders residue such Three Spice
Grinders with the green residue
yeah I'm not taking him
Melissa I'm number one I'm not taking
your money I just like
yeah it's going with you it's in your
property bag
why would I take your I'm on camera why
why in the world would I do anything
like that that's crazy
we because we don't wanna your car has
to get towed so yeah
so what'll happen
and that's why I'm here
so the reason that we take that stuff
out of the cars so that the tow truck
driver doesn't steal it
no
no you don't know
you are wrong you were wrong
you are wrong no I'm not wrong I know
that you need it
seriously what would you like to do
about taking the breath test
well you can't talk to anybody about
that right now you have to make your
decision on whether or not you want to
do the breath test first okay you will
have an opportunity to make phone calls
um and really honestly if you if you
feel your rights have been violated
there's no okay there's no there's no
rush there's no rush to talk to anybody
right this second it's not going to
change anything okay
um I have no reason to lie to you
so um we searched your car incident to
an arrest and that's what happens in the
State of Florida I know you may disagree
with me and that's okay you you are
welcome to find that answer on your own
there's no harm in that okay but I do
need to know as part of the law when
you're arrested for DUI you are required
to submit to a a breath test and or a
urine test okay
so the first portion of this is I'm
gonna ask you to do a breath test are
you willing to do that
violated
do you want to take the protest yes or
no
so let me
let me read this next portion to you
so so let me talk let me let me talk to
that point a little bit okay
a portion of this paragraph probably not
going to apply to you but some of it
does okay so your right to remain silent
has nothing to do with taking the
approved chemical test for the purpose
of determining the alcohol and our drug
content of your blood you've already
agreed to it right
it's you sign you sign the paperwork
it's on the paperwork I I don't work
there I have nothing to do with that you
know but
but I do need to know if you're going to
take that test or not
yeah okay
understand that I'm I don't get upset
about it that is completely your choices
that that you have to make there's
one right here for me
oh hold on okay we're gonna go right to
that door right there on the wall I
gotta hold you through the parking lot
okay once again
you go up just to the right side of the
door
that's good right there
yes come on
go ahead and go to the right so I can
open this to that store